louis recibió una tarjeta de regalo por
valor de 25 pesos de una tienda en línea
dedicada a la venta de música digital y
de juegos cada canción cuesta un peso y
cada juego cuesta 2 pesos y además él
quiere comprar al menos 15 artículos con
su tarjeta de regalo escribe un sistema
de desigualdades que representen el
problema e identifica el rango de
posibles compras usando una gráfica
bueno lo primero que va a hacer es
definir variables es que voy a decir que
sea m igual al número de canciones que
puede
louis comprar y bueno m por música y
después voy a tomarme ag como mi otra
variable y voy a decir que va a ser
igual a de espera espera espera de hecho
me gustaría más pensar en dos variables
completamente aleatorias así que voy a
tomarme no sé lo que se me ocurra s voy
a decir que es el número de canciones
que puede comprar y voy a decir que que
es igual al número de juegos que él
puede comprar y lo primero que quiero
que veas es que yo sé que la suma de ese
más
es decir del número de canciones más del
número de juegos tiene que ser al menos
15 esto es lo que nos dice el problema
él quiere comprar al menos 15 artículos
con su tarjeta de regalo por lo tanto es
más que tiene que ser mayor o igual que
15 el número de canciones más el número
de juegos tiene que ser mayor o igual
que los 15 artículos que al menos luis
quiere comprar puede ser igual que 15
porque podemos comprar solamente 15
artículos pero también puede ser mayor o
igual que 15 es decir puede ser 16 17 18
19 lo que sea y por otra parte el
problema nos dice que louis puede gastar
hasta 25 pesos que era lo que tenía la
tarjeta de regalo y que cada canción
cuesta un peso y que cada juego cuesta
dos pesos como podemos escribir una
desigualdad con esto bueno vamos a
escribir primero lo que está gastando
louis lo que gasta louis es la cantidad
de canciones que él va a comprar por uno
porque un peso al de cada una de estas
canciones más dos veces la cantidad de
juegos que él va a comprar y este 2 sale
porque cada uno de los juegos vale 2
pesos así que si por ejemplo nosotros
tenemos que louis compras
juegos y 4 canciones entonces tendríamos
2 por 5 10 más 4 son 14 pesos el
gastaría 14 pesos y bueno estoy
remitiendo el uno al lado de la s porque
recuerda que multiplicar por 1 es dejar
las cosas tal cual aunque cada canción
vale un peso y bueno lo que gasta tiene
que ser menor o igual que 25 pesos el
pueda gastar 25 pesos pero no se puede
pasar de 25 pesos porque es lo que tiene
en su tarjeta de regalo y ya que tenemos
este sistema de desigualdades
ahora vamos a graficar este sistema de
desigualdades así que para esto déjame
aquí graficar dos ejes y ahorita vamos a
tomar la decisión de que está en cada
uno de los ejes y por cierto solamente
voy a graficar el primer cuadrante es
decir donde ese eje son positivos este
va a ser el eje de las ss este es va a
ser el eje de las que es porque
solamente tienen sentido comprar un
número de juegos y de canciones
positivos y bueno para graficar este par
de desigualdades lo primero que me tengo
que fijar es en las líneas límite o
dicho de otra manera en los bordes y
para esto lo que puede hacer es escribir
estas desigualdades en su forma
en orden al origen y para esto voy a
despejar a mi variable s de la primera
tengo que s es mayor o igual que menos g
más 15 menos que más 15 y bueno de la
segunda tengo y mejor déjame ponerlo con
color magenta de la segunda voy a tener
si despejó a ese que éste va a ser menor
o igual que menos dos que más 25 ese va
a ser menor o igual que menos dos que
más 25 y bueno esto lo estoy haciendo
porque yo puedo asociar una ecuación la
recta a cada una de estas desigualdades
para encontrar mi borde mi frontera de
esta desigualdad así que empecemos con
la primera si te está yo tomo una
ecuación de la recta asociada a esta
misma desigualdad que me voy a encontrar
bueno que éste va a ser igual a menos g
más 15 s va a ser igual a menos g más 15
y qué pasa con esta recta si te das
cuenta corta al eje de las heces en el
valor de 15 entonces aquí tenemos el 5
el 10 el 15 y por aquí pasan la recta y
después si yo quisiera hacer es igual a
cero entonces obtendría que menos que
más 15 es igual a 0
y si te aquí despejo lo que daría kg es
igual a 15 que es igual a 15 y por lo
tanto corta elegir las que están bien en
el valor de 15 así que vamos a ponerlo
por acá aquí voy a tener el valor de 5
por aquí por aquí me voy a tomar el
valor de 10 aquí el de 15 y por aquí
también pasa mi recta y ahora si uno de
los dos puntos y como tengo mayor o
igual puedo dibujar una recta sólida es
decir en lugar de una recta punteada voy
a dibujar una recta sólida porque todo
esto también es parte de mi solución y
si te das cuenta lo que tengo es ese más
que mayor o igual que piense en la
desigualdad original por lo tanto me voy
a fijar en todo lo que está arriba de
esta recta todo lo que está arriba de
esta recta cumple esta desigualdad
cualquier punto cuyas coordenadas sean
de la forma que coma ese que cumpla esta
desigualdad tiene que tocar esta línea
recta o tiene que estar arriba de esta
recta de mi frontera por lo tanto
dejemos colorearlo también de ver de
todo lo que esté arriba de esta recta va
a cumplir esta desigualdad y tú lo
puedes verificar por ejemplo si tomamos
el 0,0 el ser
pero pues esto no va a ser mayor y white
y 15 por lo tanto no lo cumplen no está
en esta parte y si tomamos un punto aquí
por ejemplo el 15,15 15 más 15 30 lo
cual es mayor o igual que 15 por lo
tanto si cumplen esta desigualdad y si
te das cuenta son todos estos puntos
aquí ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo
que tenemos con nuestra segunda
desigualdad si nosotros buscamos el
límite o la frontera tendríamos que s es
igual a menos dos que más 25 y de igual
manera sí que vale 0 entonces el ceibal
de 25 así que aquí vamos a tener al 20
aquí el 25 y por aquí justo por aquí
pasa mi recta ahora por otra parte si
ese vale cero entonces me va a quedar
que cero es igual a menos dos que más 25
y si yo paso es del otro lado sumando me
queda que 2 que es igual a 25 y de aquí
dividiendo entre 2 me queda que gm es
igual a 25 entre 2 lo cual es 12.5 12.5
o dos enteros un medio y eso está como
por aquí cortamos al eje de las que es
justo aquí aquí tenemos al 12.5 bueno
creo que no
de hecho creo que es justo la mitad esta
sería mi mitad
justo por aquí pasa mi frontera y si te
das cuenta en frontera también la salida
porque tenemos un menor o igual por lo
tanto vamos a dibujar a que me frontera
ya tengo mi frontera o mil bordes de
todo el conjunto solución de esta
desigualdad y ahora darse cuenta que
tenemos en esta desigualdad ese menor o
igual que menos dos que más 25 o en la
desigualdad de original teníamos que s
más 2 que es menor o igual que 25 por lo
tanto todos los que están aquí abajo
todos los que están abajo de esta
frontera son parte de la solución y de
igual manera tú lo puedes verificar si
tomamos por ejemplo un punto adentro y
un punto fuera vamos a ver qué es lo que
sucede el 0,0 esto claro que se cumple
porque 0 es menor o igual que 25 y si
tomamos ahora el 15,15 15 más 2 por 15
es el mismo que tres veces 15 lo cual es
45 y 45 no es menor o igual que 25 por
lo tanto estamos bien ahora el conjunto
solución que cumple simultáneamente
ambas desigualdades es donde se
traslapan estos dos colores es decir
donde tenemos en esta gráfica de aquí
una combinación de
los colores del verde y de la gente y si
te das cuenta es justo esta parte de
aquí esta parte de aquí es donde se
traslapan estos dos colores y no
solamente esta parte también las
fronteras porque en ambas desigualdades
son desigualdades amplias por lo tanto
también tocamos estos bordes de aquí y
más aún ya podemos construir en este
problema que cualquier combinación de
canciones y de juegos que tomemos en
esta región de aquí va a cumplir ambas
desigualdades simultáneamente